[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven now
here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor Doug Batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact high-speed cameras are
fascinating they can freeze a
hummingbird's wings in mid-flight or
capture a bullet moving through the air
well now research scientists at INRs a
branch of the University of Quebec in
Canada have created the world's fastest
camera it's called teacup the camera can
capture a mind-boggling 10 trillion
frames per second that's right not
million not billion ten trillion frames
per second this doubles a previous
record of five trillion frames per
second set by Linda University's frame
camera in 2017 and they beat out mi
t--'s one trillion frame per second
camera of 2011 of course light travels
186,000 miles per second that means now
with 10 trillion frames per second this
new teacup camera is so fast it's able
to freeze a picture so precisely it can
capture the movement of light friends
you know the Bible says one of the signs
of the last days is a great increase in
knowledge stay with us we're going to
learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions welcome friends Bible
answer is live if you've got a Bible
question we encourage you to give us a
call
lines are wide open now this is a test I
repeat this is a test
tonight is the Super Bowl one of the
teams playing is Northern California we
are in Northern California I don't think
the game's over is anybody out there
listening right now so give us a call we
do have a couple of callers lined up but
if you would like to have a bible
question answered give us a call
lines are open eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven we're gonna
see if people are actually tuning in
pastor Ross to Bible answers live in the
midst of a Super Bowl one eight hundred
God says call in with your Bible
questions one eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven and you could
also be listening if you go to the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page
that's the Doug Batchelor Facebook page
or the amazing facts Facebook page you
can not only listen you can watch what
is happening here in our simple studio
and with that I guess we'll start with
prayer absolutely spy heads your Father
in Heaven we thank you that we have this
opportunity once again to open up your
word and study the scriptures and we do
ask for your blessing pray for the Holy
Spirit be with us here in the studio and
some of those who are listening whether
there being a car at home wherever they
might be we ask this in Jesus name Amen
amen ambassador you opened the program
talking about a very fast camera it's
difficulty imagine something that could
capture a frame of a picture that could
actually catch catch
capture I should say light moving across
an object I mean that's just bizarre
yeah you know it makes me think of that
prophecy in the book of Daniel chapter
12 where he's talking about the last
days and he says that knowledge will
increase and you know I I don't think
there's been any time in history like
this time that has seen and by the way
that's Daniel chapter 12 verse 4 but you
Oh Daniel
shut up the words and seal the book
until the time of the end
many will run to and fro marking we're
going very quickly from place to place
and knowledge will increase doesn't say
wisdom because man can have a lot of
knowledge build a bomb and blow up his
fellow man doesn't mean he's got wisdom
it means he's got more technology well
boy the technology of our age right now
is mind-boggling and look how much it's
has changed in one generation but this
is one of many prophecies that proves
the validity of the Bible and the time
in which we're living tonight I think we
have a special offer we've never given
away a brand new resource a magazine
that amazing fax is just produced and
it's called kingdoms in time and in this
magazine you'll find some of the most
compelling prophecies in the Bible that
have been fulfilled that prove the Bible
to be indeed inspired book and as
mentioned by Pastor Douglas is not
something that we've offered before but
we are gonna do it tonight if you'd like
to receive our brain new magazine called
kingdoms in time the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and you can ask for the
magazine kingdoms in time we'll be able
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
and if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven again that's 800 four 63 72 97 we
want to greet our friends who are
joining us on Facebook I'm pastor Doug's
Facebook page also on amazing facts
you'll notice at the bottom of the
screen we have a number you can call
that one eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven with your Bible
question we do have lines that are open
this is a good time to pick up your
phone and give us a call first caller
that we have is Patrick listening in
Toronto Patrick welcome to the program I
am pastor Doug and John how are you
doing great
thanks for calling I'm listening today
I think the Super Bowl might have just
ended I didn't get things oh we should
get a flood of calls then Don't Tell
don't say who won that's it don't be a
spoil okay I don't know my phone but
my question is that around Christmas we
had a discussion in the house for around
the holiday dinner
my stepson brought up a point which I
think he was just trying to be funny but
he said Jesus drank wine and we said no
he didn't he drank new wine and then his
aunts jumped in and said that um no
Jesus drank fermented wine so I was I
heard you talk about it before but I
just want to hopefully clarify this with
them that I at the wedding feast when
Jesus drank when Jesus made water into
wine that he didn't make six vessels
full of fermented wine and if blood at
the at the if wine also represents Jesus
blood yeah great question there's only
one word used in the Bible for grape
juice which is unfermented or wine the
pastor ross is going to look at that
verse and Isaiah for me it says as the
new wine is in the cluster I think it's
Isaiah 66 Jesus did not make alcohol for
a wedding the Bible tells us it's wine
is a mocker strong drink is raging and
Christ even at the Last Supper he told
the disciples I will not drink with the
fruit of the vine again until I drink it
with you new in the father's kingdom
Christ compares his gospel to new wine
he said you don't put new wine in old
wineskins old wineskins has their
fermentation in the embedded in the skin
new is the fresh grape juice Christ
always compared his gospel to new fresh
wine they were amazed at the wedding
they said where did you get this good
wine they get fermented wine all year
long you could typically only get fresh
wine right after harvest you have that
verse yeah I use a chapter 65 verse 8 it
says thus saith the Lord is the new wine
he's founding the cluster and once say
do not destroy it for there is a
blessing in it so it uses the word wine
there but it's clearly grape juice so
now the wine of Babylon you read about
that it makes people drunk and that's
revelation 17 look at the examples in
the Bible
Noah drank wine and he stumbled around
naked and it someone got cursed Bible
tells us that lot drank wine and he
slept with his daughters you can read
where David tried to get Uriah to go
against his conscience by getting him
drunk
so whenever alcohol was used in the
Bible and a lot of kings made some
really bad decisions drinking in the
Bible the priests were not to drink
alcohol and in fact the sons of Aaron I
get the mixed up HOF knife in it has an
eighth Avenue by here so it's off Nathan
Hanson fire came down they entered into
the sanctuary and Neeb read it and after
they were destroyed in that judgment God
told Aaron their sons were not to be
drinking wine meaning alcoholic wine
before they came into the sanctuary so
we do have a free offer that talks about
that Patrick that we'll be happy to send
you about alcohol and the Christian it's
got those verses and many others the
book is simply called the Christian and
alcohol and we'll be happy to send this
to anyone wanting to learn more about
what the Bible says with reference to
the Christian and alcohol the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again you can
just ask for that book it's called
alcohol and the Christian if you have a
Bible question the phone line is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven will bring you here into our
studio we but Sharon listening from Ohio
Sharon with the program hi thanks for
having me on I had a question tonight
about whether the devil can read your
mind
great question the Bible tells us in
second Kings I think at second Kings
chapter 9 pastor Ross for the prayer of
Solomon maybe it's verse eight chapter
eight verse 32 where he says God and God
only knows the thoughts of men's hearts
and it's in the dedication prayer and
then in mark chapter 2 it says jesus
knew their thoughts several times in the
ministry of christ he knew the thoughts
of people in the room at the feast at
Simon's house when that He healed the
man let down through the roof so God
knows what people think I believe the
devil can sometimes make an educated
yes of what we're thinking because he'll
tempt us and then kind of look at our
expression and body language to see is
he getting through but no one can read
our hearts but God nobody can read your
mind
yeah so good some people have thought
well since since the devil can't read my
mind if I pray quietly he doesn't know
what I'm saying
but don't be afraid to pray out loud
because it scares the devil ha ok good
thank you very much
alrighty thanks so much appreciate that
make a call at the behalf is let's see
man you're listening from Africa a man
you're walking with the program good
morning morning there are you doing and
your question tonight is a man in
Genesis chapter 1 verse 26 God said let
us make man in our own image
Maxon a rich people God willing wish
because what the let us make man in our
own image so I want more the people whom
God was using with was it an angel or
was it I mean other bees yeah
well I believe that when God said let us
make man in our image he's speaking to
the other members of the Godhead which
would be you know God the Father God the
Son God the spirit and in particular now
as far as the image of God in the spirit
that's a hard one to describe but both
the father and the son are described
having a form and features that are very
much like humans actually we're like God
I should say but you know talked about
the eyes of God the hair of God the feet
of God the hands of God I think it talks
about the nose of God the ears of God
and then let me see what prophet saw God
Daniel saw God envision Revelation you
have a description of God seated upon
his throne and in Chapter 1 - yeah Jesus
standing by the seven-branch candlestick
and even the holy spirit you know the
Bible says the spirit knows the heart
and can be grieved well
we can also be grieved yeah we have
characteristics characteristics yes
could sympathize and then you go to
Genesis 11 also a manual and God says
the man well I think it says the man has
become like us as in Genesis 3 knowing
good and evil so he's driven from the
garden Genesis 11 it said let us go down
and confound their language so you see
God is speaking I think the word Elohim
is a plural word God is speaking to the
other members of the Godhead in those
stories uh and we do have a free offer
that talks about the Trinity you can
read online because I know you're in
Ghana Africa right now
matter of fact my Fred Ted Wilson is
over there right now so if you see him
you send him our regards if you'd like
to receive that book or read that book
if you're outside of North America the
easiest ways just go to the website and
look up at the amazing facts website the
book on the Trinity and we'll be happy
to send that to those in North America
or you can read it for free online next
caller that we have is map listening of
Virginia Matt welcome to the program
good get real close to your phone sounds
like you're traveling well we can hear
you go ahead state your question you
hear me better oh yes as much gooder
okay okay
my question was about the devil and why
is he not destroyed when will he be
destroyed I know he was not supposed to
be destroyed for at least a thousand
years after Jesus returns or something
but my question is why isn't he already
destroyed it you know why is he kind of
like in like like he's like a buddy with
God he's like in a story of job you see
they're talking to each other making
deals and does he go back and forth
between heaven and earth or something or
can you explaining all that yeah well
I'll do my best and you know I try to
just budget about three minutes for each
question but he's not the Buddy of God
he is the arch enemy of God the word
Satan actually means
adversary he's called the accuser of the
Brethren and he is accusing God there's
a big controversy he's saying that God
is not fair God is not loving and he
said the only reason job obeys you is
because you protect him and God said
look I'm gonna I'm gonna give you enough
rope to tempt job to show you that that
is not true
and job of course love God he was
faithful even after he lost his
possessions his family his health but
yeah God could snap his fingers and
destroy the devil but the thing is the
devil has circulated through the
universities reports these false
allegations and so God must disprove the
allegations of Satan before he's
destroyed but you read in revelation 12
and I forget what verse pastor Ross
Satan has come down with great wrath
because he knows his time is short and
the devil knows his days are numbered so
when Christ comes back even after the
devil has a thousand years being bound
on this void planet in the darkness he
doesn't change he still is ready to
attack the City of God in Revelation
chapter 20 and then he's destroyed and
cast in the lake of fire and revelation
says that in Jesus says in Matthew 25 -
yeah the verse you're referring to in
Revelation revelation 12 verse 12 it
says the devil has come down to you
having great wrath because he knows he
has a short time now we do have a study
guide it says is the devil in charge of
hell and no actually that's it did God
create the devil God create a devil is
the one that would want to look at and
that talks about the origin of the devil
how did a beautiful angel end up
rebelling and we'll send that to you or
anyone wanting to learn more just after
the study guide called I did the did God
create the devil and the number to call
is 883 five six seven four seven and
again we'll send that to anyone in North
America that's such an important subject
because people thinking people and you
know Matt asked a good question if God
is good if he's loving if he's
all-powerful why is he letting the devil
go on with his rampage around the planet
and folks need to read that lesson so we
hope you'll send for that study guide
you know we also have a video that you
can take a look at it's called cosmic
conflict
I think it's free on YouTube now
everything we produce pretty soon it's
on YouTube
so yeah just type cosmic conflict into
YouTube and it'll be the one with
amazing facts all right Mick Foley look
we have he's Wayne listening in Idaho
Wayne welcome to the program thank you
I have a question for you I was talking
with one of my friends and they were
mentioning Habakkuk 2 2 and I'm trying
to figure out what these uh look these
stones are supposed to write on alright
let me go there real quick Habakkuk
chapter 2 verse 2 maybe I can read that
why don't you do that it says then the
Lord answered NSYNC to be right the
vision make it plain on tables that they
might be able to run who reads it for
the vision he's yet for an appointed
time yeah when something was written in
itched in stone in the Bible it
represented its enduring nature and a
prophecy of God never fails jesus said
heaven and earth will pass away my word
will not pass away and Christ compares
his word to a rock he that hears these
words of mine and does them is like the
wise man who builds on the rock Ten
Commandments were etched in stone so
this is a vision and I think this was a
vision if I'm not mistaken about the
Lord's coming because it says wait for
it though it seems to tarry it will not
tarry it will surely come and the just
will live by faith
at least I've heard it applied that way
a couple of times so I don't know if
that helps a little bit but this is a
prophecy of Habakkuk that was talking
about the return of the Lord okay so
okay thank you
alrighty thank you very much appreciate
your call in your question next hole of
the wave is Niles listening in
Georgetown Donna
Niles welcome to the program
all right thank you for calling them
yeah my question is um what does the
Bible say about what's untimely dead
when someone dies is that their time
reaches or Niles that's a good question
you know I think that we've got to be
careful sometimes some religions teach
that whenever someone dies it was God's
will you know my Muslim friends will say
well it must have been the will of Allah
not everything that happens in the world
today is God's will the reason Jesus
tells us in the Lord's Prayer to pray
thy will be done is because there is a
battle in the world between the free
will that God has given every human and
the perfect will of God
people many times do things that is not
the will of God sometimes I think
Solomon said in Ecclesiastes time and
chance happens to all and you know there
are good people in the Bible that were
obeying God and they got sick and died
like the prophet Enoch or like the
soldier Jonathan was a faithful servant
of God but he died in battle I mean
sometimes people think if you're serving
God then nothing will ever go wrong and
you won't die prematurely but the Bible
doesn't tell us that the Bible says
there's a there's evil in the world
innocent people suffer at the hands of
the wicked and the wicked will be judged
for that there's disease in the world
because of the devil Christ actually
healed a lady and he says Satan has
bound this lady for 18 years she had
been afflicted by this illness that
comes from the devil so sometimes people
do die prematurely and in when you
people need to know that you know the
Lord he comforts and he empathizes and
God is not willing that any should
perish so he certainly understands that
there is there's evil and heartache in
the world
diversity referring to there is
Ecclesiastes 9 verse 11 yeah so God can
work all things together for good but
sometimes that you know the devil will
cause problems
look at we just talked about Jobe mm-hmm
the devil killed his family that wasn't
God's well I mean the devil just he's
wicked so hey Thank You Niles I hope
that helps a little you would also enjoy
that free lesson on did God create a
devil talks about the suffering in the
world and why it happens next one of the
babies Tish listening in Las Vegas Tish
welcome to the program hi there thank
you for having me on can you hear me yes
loud and clear even the last question
that was asked and answered it's all
falls into my um I guess my confusion
I'm having I'm really struggling the
more that I learned and the higher my
level of spiritual development grows I'm
just really not clear on predestination
and like what's allowed to happen and
what I should be praying for or just
letting or just I don't know what that
what I'm going what's going to happen to
me and what's not I guess that make
sense well I think it does because
you're you're asking a question that is
connected with a lot of people who are
wondering what does predestination mean
in other words has God already decided
who's going to be saved and you don't
really have a choice you just got to
watch it play out find out in eternity
or does the Lord want everyone to be
saved and you have a free choice to
choose God and so the even among
Christians one of the most hotly debated
subjects is the subject of free will and
predestination pastor Ross and I are
from the old school that believes that
God is not willing that any one perish
God did not pre-ordained that only
certain people should be saved he wants
everyone to be saved you can read the
course that 2nd Peter chapter 3 he's not
willing that any should perish and then
you can read and you know John 3:16
whosoever believes in him our revelation
ends in chapter 22 of the book by saying
who
so error would like to take the water of
life come and drink freely so summer
predestination makes it sound like God
has he's only chosen certain people that
are going to you know hear his spirit
and respond but I think God sends a
spirit and his providence into every
life not willing that any should perish
but desiring all men to come to
repentance and so you should be praying
that you know you'll be knowing God's
will and surrendering to his will is
that making sense it's helping me it's a
it's going to be a process I see that
and you know we've got a great book tsch
that talks about the subject of
predestination and we'd love to send you
a free copy and you know week old kind
of save man choose to be lost
and it deals with that very subject and
if you just call the number our resource
number it's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and after the
book can I save man choose to be lost I
will be able to send this to you to show
anyone wanting to learn more about the
subject of what is predestination what
does the Bible teach next one of the we
have is Kevin listening in Orlando
Florida Kevin welcome to the program
good evening evening Kevin my question
my question is well okay if someone is
married and individual commits adultery
and God is the only one that sees it but
although the individual has evidence
what what does the Bible say about
confession when it comes to that
scenario so you confess to your spouse
or to God well of course you would
always confess a sin to God but you know
that's let me say if you don't mind
Kevin I'm going to try and state your
question a different way a businessman
goes on a trip he's got wife and kids
have been happily married for 10 years
and while he's on the business trip in a
moment of weakness the strange
opportunity
and he commits adultery he's terribly
ashamed he's never gonna see this person
again he's in another country comes home
and he's thinking you know he's asked
God to forgive him do I do I tell my
wife it's gonna break her heart she
might divorce me if I don't tell her we
can you know just keep our happy
marriage what do you do in a situation
like that well I'm of the opinion that
you're always going to have your
conscience on to you
and in a situation like that you would
probably want to sit your spouse down
and say you know I've got to tell you
something I love you and the only reason
I'm telling you is because I want to
have absolute trust in a relationship
and I've made a terrible mistake and I
think that you need to come clean
otherwise you've got like a secret yeah
you always pretend that you're faithful
but you weren't and I think that in
order for there to be healing in your
own life that's one of those cases where
you would want to confess now if you've
been out gossiping about your friends
and you're convicted you don't have to
go tell all your friends you know I was
gossiping about you that won't help
anybody but when there's a vow and a
covenant between you and your spouse and
that's been violated I think to maintain
trust you need to be open about that
anyway I hope we answered your question
Kevin we're gonna come back in just a
few minutes don't go away friends we see
you waiting Carol Daryl Greg Tom we're
coming back with more Bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
chart and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com you're
listening to Bible answers live where
every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 soldiers or
post-traumatic stress disorder and they
have fear quite often and I know that
that fear does not come from above not
with him because they have anxiety they
struggle with fear and worry you know
that's a great question I I just
finished a book so it's not printed yet
it's in the process of the editorial
prophecy process and it's called how to
live in fear how to live in peace when
you're scared to death and a lot of
people struggle with worry and I think I
mister quoted the title how to live in
peace when you're worried to death
that's it yeah
a lot of people struggle with worrying
folks I have people all the time say
does this mean that I have no faith that
I am lost because I worry you know even
in the Bible there's Psalms that say
when my heart is anxious I will turn to
thee well before he could turn to God
his heart was anxious that's written by
David and so you know there's a number
of people of faith in the Bible that
stress Elijah a great man of faith he
got a little worried when Jezebel said
I'm gonna kill you by tomorrow and he
ran for his life and Jonah was worried
he was a prophet of God
so because we go through episodes of
worry doesn't mean that God is not
working in our life everybody you know
has varying degrees of concern for
either real problems or imagined
problems you don't want your life to be
controlled by imaginary problems and you
know it just Rob's it Rob's today of
it's a joy and casts a shadow on
tomorrow but um Jesus does offer a peace
that passes understanding and when we
are really basking in the holy spirit
and when we were baptized in the spirit
I believe it brings a peace into the
life that you just know God loves you
you know God is on the throne you know
God is not worried and that he is gonna
watch out for you as you trust your life
to him doesn't mean he doesn't want us
to think or use our heads or plan but he
doesn't want us to be living constantly
in fear so don't beat up on yourself
Carla if sometimes you are concerned or
afraid but at the same time look for
seek after pursue that peace you know
Jesus whenever he met the apostles he
said where's your faith have more peace
peace unto you he's always saying peace
unto you and he calmed the storm you see
he can calm your heart all right well
thank you for your call
Carla next goal of the behaved is Tom
listening in Oklahoma Tom welcome to the
program how are you doing today doing
good thanks for calling and your
question I just want to say first of all
I want to say I really love
y'all are working for the Lord it's
really fantastic
well thank you we sure enjoy what we do
and it's a privilege to do it my
question is Isaiah 66 17 and coronavirus
how does this fit in prophesy prior to
Jesus return alright well let me read
that verse for those who are looking you
haven't already there pastor oh I do yep
we're looking at Isaiah 66 verse 17 it
says those who sanctify themselves and
purify themselves to go to the gardens
after an idol in the midst eating
swine's flesh and the abomination in the
mouth shall be consumed together saith
the Lord
now as some people probably know that
the coronavirus as with many of these
very deadly flu viruses it is usually
caused because of people living in close
proximity to animals that are being bred
for food usually the swine flu of course
came from the swine and they're still
not sure whether this virus or I'm not
sure if it came from swine or from birds
it's usually one of the two that they in
China you know I've been there several
times they have a lot of people live in
close proximity with these animals and
sometimes these viruses mutate and go
from animal to human and then the
antibiotics and our natural defenses are
not all ready for that so here it
describes people that are worshipping
idols and they're eating swine's flesh
in Isaiah and the mouse and the question
is wondering is the coronavirus
connected with that is that what you're
wanting to know tom yeah sure do well
you know I don't think specifically
because a person might pick up the
coronavirus that didn't pray to idols
and eat swine they they're getting it
from humans but I do think that the
Bible is setting down an example for us
that it's it's better for us to avoid
now you're of course I'm biased I'm a
vegetarian
so I think it's humans are a lot better
off if we're not mass breeding animals
to slaughter and eat them you know we do
have a verse in scripture that talks
about at the end of time Matthew 24
Jesus said nation shall rise against
nation Kingdom against Kingdom there
shall be famines pestilence earthquakes
in laying places so they are gonna be
these these plagues these diseases that
sort of sweep across the world and it
looks like we're kind of hitting into
something new here with this this virus
yeah I've watched a study a presentation
that was given by a doctor last night on
the subject and it's probably being
underreported you know whether it'll be
a pandemic in North America you know we
certainly hope not but I think they're
taking all human precautions to avoid
that but I think it is going to be more
common many people don't know that there
was a flu in 1918 that killed more
people than World War one up to 50
million people died from that 1918
Spanish flu they called it and anyway
yeah so one of the signs jesus said
plagues in the last days pestilence hope
that helps Tom thank you so much for
your call you'll enjoy the new magazine
we're offering tonight called kingdoms
and time.40 prophecies that prove the
Bible's true
beautifully illustrated magazine if
you'd like to receive that the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven asked for the
magazine called kingdoms in time Carroll
is listening from New York Carol welcome
to the program good evening how are you
we're blessed how are you I'm doing fine
thank you
my question is in Hebrews 13:2 it says
be not forgetful to entertain strangers
for thereby some have entertained angels
unawares can you explain this place
isn't that we're living it's angels
living on earth
yes I believe angels are living on earth
several things that he talks about in
Hebrews the writer we believe it's Paul
who wrote the book of Hebrews he
rehearses events in the Old Testament if
you read in chapter 11 he talks about
through
faith they stopped the mouths of lions
well that's Daniel Lyons then through
faith they quenched the violence of the
fire that's Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego in the fiery furnace it says
they were sawn asunder that's talking
about Isaiah well here he's saying don't
forget to entertain strangers some have
unwittingly entertained angels well when
when Locke first invited the Angels into
his house he thought they were men
eventually he saw they were angels and
there are other examples in the Bible
where people brought in labor ham at
first so people walking and thinking
that they were just individuals that
were in need of some food he he
ministered to them he provided food for
them well little did I realize he had
the wages but it was also the angel of
the Lord which is Christ yeah yeah so I
and I'm thinking my mind is a little
blank right now but I think there's
another example where someone invited
angels in and so he's saying don't
neglect the the gift of hospitality you
know Jesus said and as much as you do it
to the least of these you do it to me
and we might be surprised in the kingdom
to know that we gave gave a ride to a
hitchhiker that turned out to be an
angel and they often bless in their in
their path to hope that helps a little
Carol yeah I kind of know all right well
thank you so much appreciate your
question next quality' behalf he's
calling from Florida we've got Darryl
Darryl welcome to the program Darrell
Darrell you know okay yeah in Christian
pastor John yes you know sometimes I
hear pastors say things like you know as
long as you have faith and right
standing with God you're in his will
that he'll deliver you in times of
trouble and I kind of cringe when I hear
that because I know that sometimes he
does like Daniel Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego but then sometimes you know he
chooses not to like Isaiah when he was
all in half or John the Baptist when he
was beheaded or the says in Revelation
the souls under the altar that that uh
that you know we're martyrs for Christ
yeah yeah so you know I think my
question is what is the right approach
when you know like a baby Christian is
is asking you will you know will God
deliver me you know what is this and
that happens and they're you know scared
about you know persecution or whatever I
mean what do you think is a balanced
approach because you can't just tell
them okay well God will definitely
deliver you because sometimes he chooses
not to yeah that that's absolutely true
you can see several cases in the Bible
as you've named we're faithful people
have struggled and been persecuted you
know Jezebel God delivered Elijah but
she killed a whole lot of prophets
before that - and it says you know
Isaiah Elijah rather said to God they've
slain your prophets and look what they
did to Jesus and of the Twelve Apostles
only the Apostle John died of old age
now there were many times God did
miraculously deliver the apostles before
they finally got them you know Paul was
stoned while then he got up and walked
away but he later was executed by Nero
and you know Peter was broken out of
prison before his execution so God
delivered them several times and finally
said okay I'm gonna let you go to sleep
for me now and so I think that the the
key is you just say you just asked for
God's protection you ask for his
deliverance I had a close call today and
I know God was taking care of me and I
thank them for it but you know we
shouldn't tempt the Lord and jump off
the temple right and I think we should
ask him to have you know be faithful
unto death so that we can receive a
crown of life yeah exactly and you know
for a believer if you die saved all of
your problems are over
so you know I know that sounds
simplistic but it's really
true a Christian should live in faith
you worry about family and friends you
may leave behind but you know if we're
being faithful it's like the the
evangelist Whitfield used to say I'm
immortal until my work is done he
figured whenever God wants me I'm his
and there was a great missionary named
Patton that went to the new her buddies
and I think it was where Fiji is now and
they said don't go the cannibals will
eat you and he said I'm not worried
about that he said if I die here I'll
meet my worms if I'm eaten by cannibals
how I get eaten doesn't matter it's up
to God so he just had a real tease that
I'm gonna go serve the Lord what happens
happens that's it's a good attitude God
did deliver him by the way he died of
old age so hey thank you so much good
question Daryl make fun of it we have
Greg is listening in Minnesota Greg
welcome to the program hi Greg
yon might have your mute on there you
are all right if we've got Minnesota on
our can you move to Minnesota for this
call
no I'm sorry go ahead Greg from Michigan
got it okay my question is about the
person Matthew where Jesus says that if
the enemy strikes us on one cheek that
we should turn the other cheek and the
reason it's of special interest because
somebody had suggested that at that time
that there was some significance to the
use of striking somebody with one hand
versus the other and that the verse
doesn't suggest that we should just give
ourselves up to our enemies but there
are some other significance to it base
to the culture and the reasoning of
striking with one hand versus the other
you know I vaguely remember hearing
somebody go a little deeper into that I
don't remember the details there may
have been a custom I think the principle
is the same that sometimes the the Jews
were at this time occupied by
the Romans and sometimes the Roman
soldiers were a little bit rough on them
they'd say you need to carry my ear and
so Jesus said look if they compel you to
carry their their supplies for a mile
shock them and say and they'll let me
carry for two if they strike you on one
cheek offer them the other and I think
that he's saying this to a people that
were being oppressed by the Romans that
they shouldn't hate their enemies but
love them and not retaliate now there
may have been another custom among the
Jews that I heard about but I think the
principle is always true that in our
interpersonal relationships we can
choose to embrace abuse and not
retaliate because sometimes you can
overcome evil with good and when people
say realize that you're not gonna fight
them I heard about this guy in the
British Army in India and he used to be
the toughest man in the ranks he was a
boxer and he became a Christian and
every his fellow soldiers he wouldn't go
drink with him anymore he wanted to
engage in dirty jokes and they just were
a little convicted and so one guy had
been inebriated he went up and he
punched this new Christian who was very
strong and he wouldn't retaliate and he
just he'd stood there he said you know
I'm here if you want to hit me for the
Lord and it broke the other guy's heart
he said I didn't expect you to respond
that way and so you you fight evil with
good you don't fight evil with evil now
it's not saying that policemen should
just let robbers rob banks you know you
rob this bank will give you another one
it's not talking about how government's
deal it's talking about inner
interpersonal relationships it doesn't
mean you stand by and let someone hit
your wife it's not what it's saying but
in our personal relationships sometimes
he said if someone's gonna see you and
say I want your shirt say like I'll give
you my coat too and I think part of the
idea of being slapped on the face by
somebody was was an insult and they were
expecting you to retaliate in somewhere
or another of course in the Old English
society to be slapped on the face or to
be hit the glove or something made that
they wanted to have a duel and you know
I wanted you to fight but Jesus said you
know
don't take vengeance on the wickedly let
God deal with that you be faithful be a
good witness yeah we have a we lost a
vice president in a dual America for
that any thanks Greg hope that helps a
little bit yes it does thank you very
much all right take care
all right pastor Doug you can see you on
next Coley's I think it's mark right
yeah calling from Auclair Michigan you
there mark hello hi hello yes you're on
the line hi yeah thanks for taking my
call
hey I had a question I was reading
Deuteronomy chapter 9 and 10 and I it
recounts how Moses went up to the
mountain and got the commandments but he
was there for 40 days and 40 nights and
he fasted then later on though on in
verse 18 it says because Israel
corrupted themselves he broke the the
tables of stone and then he fasted again
for 40 days so that the Lord wouldn't
destroy them and I kept reading and I
sneaked in chapter 25 there was another
40 days and 40 nights and I kept reading
again in chapter 10 and I think in verse
10 it says there was another forty days
did he actually fast four times for
forty days and forty nights or am i
reading that wrong well let me let's
read it together here in Deuteronomy
chapter 9 and I'm gonna go to verse 18
after he cast the Ten Commandments out
of his hand I fell down before the Lord
at the first forty days and forty nights
I neither ate bread nor drink water
because of your sin which he committed
in doing wickedly it sounds like you
fasted again 40 days and 40 nights
because of their sins he when he's first
up on the mountain getting the law he's
fast he's in the presence of God he's
not even hungry it's like when Elisha
ate that angel food he went 40 days
without eating because he was so
nourished on the power of God but now I
think Moses is actually fasting but the
Lord listened to me yes so he did fast
again another 40 days in and he was
mediating he was interceding for the
people so yeah when he goes back up the
mountain gets the Ten Commandments I
don't think it says let me see here 40
days I kept prostrating myself before
the law
I think it's talking about the same time
in verse 27 so it's telling us that he
fasted another forty days and forty
nights in repentance for the sin of the
people that's the same one you read
about earlier if I'm not mistaken I've
been mistaken before but I think I think
you're right that he did fast again
after he got the Ten Commandments
repenting for the people and interceding
for the people but when he went back up
the mountain and got the Ten
Commandments again I don't think he
spent another forty days up there
because part of the original 40 days was
getting the plans for the sanctuary and
everything he already had that God
didn't need another forty days to write
the Ten Commandments but what's y'all
looking at past Ross to see if I've got
it right you know I think you're right
pastor Doug I don't have the verse in
front of me but typically we you
understand that it was a forty day
without eating and drinking in the
presence of God yeah and of course that
was a type of what Christ would do and
he came on the earth he didn't leave
fast for forty days he did drink water
though but he fasted for forty days from
food yeah so I don't think when he went
back up with the two tables for God to
Rhian scribe the law that he was there
another forty days I'm looking I don't
see that you know he's one of the quick
thought on that the Bible talks of Moses
and Elijah as being a type of the law
and the prophets so you have Moses
fasting for forty days you have Elijah
who went in the strength of that food
for forty days and then you have Jesus
and of course you have Moses and Elijah
that appeared with Jesus on the Mount of
Transfiguration there are the three
individuals that fasted forty days in
the Bible
very good hey thank you Mark you know we
do have a lesson that talks about the
law of God it's called written in stone
we'll be happy to send you a free copy
the number to call if you'd like to
receive that he's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
just ask for the study guide called
written in stone we'll send it to anyone
who calls and asks we've got cliff
listening in Florida cliff welcome to
the program hi hi how are you doing John
3:13 means all right we're gonna go
there right now and maybe pastor us you
want to read that Gospel of John not it
first letter John 3:30 yes it says no
one has ascended up to
but he has come down from heaven that is
the son of man who is in heaven yeah
that doesn't mean when it says no one
has ascended to heaven I don't think
that Jesus is saying Elijah did not
ascend Enoch did not ascend Moses did
not ascend because the Bible says that
they did ascend to heaven
I think Christ is saying no man has gone
up to heaven and come back down
to tell us and reveal the plan of
salvation and who the father is except
me that you know the son of God and so
Jesus is really talking about that he is
the one who's been sent from the father
you know I think the key to understand
verse 13 he's looking at verse 12 Jesus
is talking about heavenly things isn't
if I told you earthly things you do not
know do not believe how would you
understand if I tell you heavenly things
and he says no one has ascended up to
heaven meaning to receive these heavenly
things but he has come down from heaven
so that kind of gives a little bit of
the context because we do know from
Scripture that they have been other
individuals that have ascended up to
heaven like Enoch and Elijah and Moses
was resurrected yeah so but they didn't
come back down to get in till I tell
Christ it so Jesus is the only man that
came down from heaven bringing truth
from God does that make sense
okay yeah all right hey thank you so
much for your call maybe follow that we
have these rose from me listening in
Clovis California rose from me walking
to the program yeah I'm here yeah well
we got about two minutes so your
question tonight 24 through 26 when god
when it says that and he came up to pass
by the way the end that the Lord met him
and sought to kill him was God trying to
kill Moses I'm not that's well that's
good you know it also talks about not
just Moses but at one time it says the
angel stood against Balaam and he was
going to slay him and the angel was
opposed to David when he numbered Israel
God does not miss it's not like God ever
fires at someone who says you know I was
off a little bit I miss
God does not swing a sword at someone
and say I missed when it says the Lord
was gonna slay him it simply means that
Moses was facing judgment now the
background real quick
Moses while he was in the wilderness for
forty years with he married Zipporah he
had two children with sapore he knew God
was going to use him to do a great work
and leading the people out of Egypt he
had not even circumcised his own son and
and that was a very important covenant
for every Hebrew man and so Moses is on
his way back to Egypt evidently Zipporah
didn't want to do that she said that's
kind of barbaric custom I'm guessing she
they had some disagreement cuz finally
when God says Moses you're the man of
the family you're supposed to lead by
example and tell your wife that the boy
needs to be circumcised so Sephora does
it she says okay you know you're a
bloody man this is this is this is a
barbaric practice and but he obeyed what
God told him to do and at that point I
think that his wife was sent back home
he went on with it just Aaron to meet
with the elders but it means that he was
under the judgment of God because he was
disobeying God God had been convicting
Moses they take care of this and he
didn't do it
Thank You rosemary you know we're out of
time for new questions tonight and so
Bob Carol Raj if we don't get to you
tonight I hope you'll give us another
chance for our listening friends we hope
that you'll visit amazing facts the
website it's amazing facts dot o-r-g
just amazing facts not orgy you can
visit our youtube page and listen to
sermons study our material download our
books we're just trying to get the truth
out because jesus is coming again and
the truth will set you free
god bless still we study next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit a
book store calm
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past Alexander the Great becomes
king when he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy a hundred and fifty
years in advance Cyrus had been named
Rahm was violent they were ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
see his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at